look when you look at Tesla it's gotten
off to a pretty rough start in 2015 down
at least five percent in over the past
12 months it's basically treaded water
even as the broader market returned more
than sixteen percent of course if you
bought the stock when it IP owed at
seventeen you're sitting pretty but
today's chart shows how fundamentals are
starting to drive the share price let's
take a look the yellow line tracks
analysts estimates for Tesla's first
quarter 2015 sales steadily been
ratcheted down it's now at just over 1
billion dollars the white line tracks
Tesla's share price which peaked at 291
dollars in September and has been losing
ground ever since today Bank of America
analyst John lovallo cut his price
target on the stock 265 from 70 not
surprisingly he already had an
underperform rating on the stock scarlet
a call of $65 when the stocks about two
hundred dollars means the analysts
expects a drop of almost seventy percent
you look at the Bloomberg terminal no
one even comes close with the second
lowest price target what around 120
dollars yeah put it this way mark
there's a 335 dollar gulf between the
highest price target in a bloomberg
survey of analysts and this most recent
revised price target from Bank of
America the turn in the stock may have
come last September but the fourth
quarter earnings report from the company
earlier this month was reality check
there was an unexpected loss in the
fourth quarter a larger than expected
capex plan for the year in overly rosy
outlook in China Bank of America's John
lovallo says that Tesla's using a
strategy of issuing long term targets
that are intended maybe to offset or
distract from a steady stream of
negative news and weak financial results
that include a cash burn long-term goals
like diversifying into home battery
systems over the next six months which
Bloomberg View columnist Edward
Niedermayer calls a distracting dead end
but maybe marca looking at Tesla's a
normal company could be the mistake here
because Niedermayer writes in bloomberg
view that like space travel itself
buying a Tesla were a share of the
company isn't something you do because
you expect it to return some specific
return but because it appeals to some
deep human need for adventure but that
adventure may just cost you and yeah
oh okay but Scarlett talk to me about
the bullish argument here demands not a
problem is that what they're saying well
the bullish analyst will say that
demands not a problem Stifel Nicolaus
makes that point and they have the
highest price target on Tessa with four
hundred dollars over the next twelve
months but the pushback from bank of
america and other skeptics is that the
economics of electric vehicles are not
as compelling as investors may have
priced in customer deposits on the
balance sheet for instance reservation
payments are not the best gauge of
demand because they're influenced by
vehicle mix and regional distribution so
the issue perhaps is a lack of demand
and tesla appears to be pulling back on
production according to make of America
Scarlett I got to ask you about the the
the China reference you mentioned ago
because you said Rover overly optimistic
yeah there was some concern that
charging might be difficult in China
right yes and that perception has led to
a big drop-off in actual sales in china